dr. storm we gave you six years and
millions of dollars and you gave us
nothing what's different now Reed
Richards emails answers to questions we
don't even know the last gift this is
our chance to learn more about our
planet and maybe even save I watch it it
meets my daughter's suit you want to be
famous
I just want my work to make a difference
sure greed this guy doesn't take orders
well yeah especially for people who say
I don't take orders well don't let any
of these lab coats give you any crap bye
well if I do I know who to call the
muscle I gotta say it's fun having you
here but yeah what you've created here
is incredible yeah we're good
they just cracked interdimensional
travel
all I want to know is where are my
children or AB survived all exhibit
unique physical conditions
just won't fix my friends you can't fix
this you should use these powers to help
people
you open the door you don't know how to
close you don't know anything about
what's going
Oh disconnect
if you want to stop him
it's gonna take everything you have
how long until he's in two minutes
might be a little list